now we're talking about
florida wall street businesses and
fabulously wealthy money managers live
in new york to go to warmer climate a
smaller
tax bill hardly a new phenomenon it's
the first time uh industry heavyweights
have questioned new york's future as a
home with a big finance okay
i suspect florida will soon rival new
york as a financial
financial hub leon cooperman the hedge
fund manager who founded new york based
omega advisors told business and said in
an email
tax and spend has been the northeast
policy
it has to change or new york jersey
connecticut will become
ghost towns okay ghost towns this is a
guy
that's from the industry talking about
there's going to be a ghost town up
there and then some other data
blackstone the world's largest private
equity firm headquartered on park avenue
manhattan is opening up an office in
miami with plans to bring 215 technology
focused jobs there from so-called back
office employees handling technology
systems from
miami then companies aren't just looking
they are signing
leases and preparing to physically move
employees in before the end of the year
to shave
dollars off their tax bill last year
florida dropped its corporate tax rate
from 5.5
to 4.458 beautiful thing to hear in new
york that rate is six and a half percent
in connecticut
where many hedge funds are based at
seven and a half percent despite
florida's low rate of 2019 investigation
by the orlando centennial found that 99
of all businesses
in the state pay no corporate income tax
at all say that last part again
99 of all businesses in the state pay no
corporate tax income tax at all
how do they get away with that 99 let me
tell you
if they do if they do yeah good for
florida
good for floyd you know who benefits
from that i'll be employees
those only won jobs okay if i was an
employee i wouldn't be complaining about
that too much
because those that money is going to get
to jobs
jobs creates what an income for people
when people make income who do they not
rely on the government
who wins the state of florida wins i 100
agree that those places could be pseudo
ghost towns
because right now if you do a cost or a
risk benefit analysis
you know what's what's the benefit of
staying
you can't even eat in a restaurant okay
and it's not like that's gonna change
anytime soon
if you have the wherewithal to say screw
it i'm moving either as an individual or
as a company
and there's a better situation there
they're going to flock i mean this is
real
i mean they are going to blow out of
there out of the northeast
look the the the shutdowns they're not
going to stop
they're just going to find another
reason to not allow us to eat in
restaurants or something
i am 100 convinced of this okay but some
states have a different philosophy
and it's across the board watch a
football game the nfl should be so
grateful that the super bowl is in
florida this year
because look they're already having
about 20 000 fans per game for college
games for the tampa bay bucks
for the miami dolphins they're going to
be able to probably put 40 or 50 000
people in for the super bowl as opposed
to if it was in a different state that
was shut down
they'd have no fans whatsoever so i mean
it is two completely different
we are at a tipping point time in this
country
smart people are making decisions what
makes sense for the long term and
getting the hell out of the northeast
for a lot of people makes sense
so uh clearly th this is a conversation
that's been going on for a long time in
florida
again i live in miami this the new
yorker the
the new yorkers flooding miami is
nothing new obviously since covid
um people have said all right i can work
remotely now like what the hell am i
doing at this point
so my question to you is because
whatever's going on in new york is also
going on in california it's like yin
yang same thing
so at what point do you say all right
i'm moving from la you love la you live
there
you rail against the policies you rail
against living there you rail against
the taxes but my question is
at what point do you actually and i'm
not saying this disrespectfully
at what point do you put your money
where your mouth is then move it's when
you have an opportunity when you have a
reason to move you're not going to do it
just for the
time but by the just so you know tom and
his family
would be ready to move anywhere if
there's an opportunity that comes up and
i'm more
i'm more personifying what someone would
think i'm not
you're not specifically speaking about
i'm not saying tom per se but i am
saying give me a glimpse as
you live in california you love it there
i've seen where you live manhattan beach
you want to be there but there's like
you're like but you're thinking about
leaving at what point do you leave
though but are you asking yeah i'm
asking
it's for yourself but also put yourself
in i'm not going to move for the sake of
people
because it'd be too hard of a cell it'd
be impossible i have kids you know
teenager
so that and my other my older daughter
lives there um so it would have to make
sense and then you go
done no no-brainer what he just said is
most people
kids family uh habit
you're used to it i've been living there
i know the freeways i know it's weird
stuff like when i came to texas the most
annoying thing to me was
getting used to these exits and there's
roundabouts you know i think it's i
think it's harder to drive here than l.a
yeah i really do i i'm not joking i get
lost here more than i ever got another
i never got lost you have no heart how
clue how hard it is to uber around here
to get an uber yeah i don't know if
you're going left right but by the way
stay on this point
yeah and and give me some insight
because oh we've been talking about this
for a while but at what point you say
i screw it i am moving you're not seeing
it already i mean
you got to realize so there's a there's
a few different camps the following
camps
those who left a long time ago we're not
talking about those people let me go
through it for you yeah those who left a
long time ago
the second camp is those who just left
the third camp is those who are prepared
are about to leave but no one knows
about it and there are those
who are in the tipping point about to
make a decision
don't think for a moment there isn't a
big community of people if i would have
told you larry ellison's moving to
california
moving to texas that's oracle oracle
yeah of course would you have said oh
yeah
uh h elon musk elon musk yes
and it's just these are these are the
billionaire the billionaire class yeah
they have a lot of reasons to you know
i'm talking normal people working people
did i put my house on the market the
other day
just two years ago no joke yeah i put my
house on the market two years ago
for one year was our on the market we
got
nothing no joke i put my house on the
market last week
24 hours two offers we gave them 20
12 more hours to make their final bid
till 12 o'clock they both came to a max
offer full price
and they said we're in one can we
everything just it's
so are you about to make an announcement
no no i'm not making any announcement
the announcement i'm trying to make you
is the fact that things
are moving so quickly that it's like the
real estate's like here
just go in yeah that's true if you're
sitting in arizona dude there's nothing
to rent today
there's nothing to rent today i'll give
you another question so i i was running
a 14 bedroom house in lake tahoe
that's where we go for christmas we like
to go to lake tahoe okay
announcement lake tahoe shutdown
heavenly
down ski slope shutdown everything's
shut down you can't party internally
together i call my guy i'm like dude
what the hell happened it says man i'm
sorry
here they give the money back right it's
a fat check they give the money back
i call my brokers three of them we will
need a vacation rental home
call on every single place hey how about
this place no you don't want to go there
because they may shut down new york
how about this place you don't want to
go to colorado because they may shut
down how about this place no you may i
wouldn't go there
so then he says just look at red states
the guy's a liberal
he said listen situation like this as a
person on the left
just look at red states what's a red
state obviously florida is not red is
purple but it's a little bit more
conservative desantis is running it
he said your best bet is going to
florida for vacation during christmas
what a thing to say see these are behind
closed doors that people who are
spending money are realizing where money
is going
to people are making if i want to go to
vacation and i want to be by the beach i
want to be summer golf all that you know
what
it would have been arizona it would have
been at the palm springs not today
now it's the other direction very the
way people spend their money
is it tough to find a place out there
now where florida every house in palm
beach is sold out
wow rent everything is gone the guy's
like look
here's here's what the guy said to me
make an offer because this thing's
leaving i'm like yeah this is a sales
pitch
you know what happened we lost one of
them so the other realtor that called me
says pat
i'm telling you i'm like dude don't
worry about it here you go just take the
damn money
we need a place for the family because
you're competing against the world
essentially
so so what they're doing is they're
helping states like
florida texas washington hence the three
richest people in the world live where
two of them live in washington state no
taxes bazels and and
uh gates and the other one just moved to
texas yeah
musk no state income taxes so these are
all going to places where they don't pay
state income tax
you're going to start feeling this very
very quickly
[Music]
you